tell you what it's Wednesday and I'm
shut up man don't don't [ __ ] say shut
up to me like that shut up dude no I
won't shut up and i and i'm and i'm just
want to keep things i want to keep
things real mellow today you're not
amped up now I want to keep things cut
your hair dude yeah I got it yourself no
I didn't you [ __ ] [ __ ] I just
haven't put any product in it so I don't
need you looking at my fuzzy ostrich
head right now okay because when I put
product in it no no don't no don't go
hmm hold on it will come together will
not come together we'll spread out more
no I have like sickening pomade okay so
I'm keeping it close to the bone you
look at your human vulture no oh you
look like your bulb culture no Gymboree
a vulture don't say that same haircut as
AB daughters say that I don't see the
problem in people like no big Tom that's
a you're not cultures always portrayed
in a nice light click on the far right
the ball Bulger sir no matter who they
can't refer to me as a ball as a vulture
vulture head vulture you call me vulture
head of the vulture I seek out the
vulture mm-hmm all right there no one
celebrates it's not that far off I mean
look I mean that's right there that's a
good one no one celebrates the vulture
do they because Disney made them super
evil and all the cartoons
do you remember what movie was it where
the vulture trust he's he's sacrificed
on the tree of woe this is the cartoon
no sacrifice me I'm the diary of woe and
the vultures start trying to eat his
eyes and he [ __ ] reaches over and
bites one the Bible
no ready Arnold Schwarzenegger in first
yeah first Conan old school do now
[ __ ] old school dude if I just
completely flipping scripts here I was
coming from Hollywood from CBS then I'm
pulling out like I'm going down Fairfax
I'm pulling out you know cars park on
the side like at the meters
yeah this like Honda or something darts
in front of me like who are you and
you're I'm in my Ferrari
no I'm in the Raptor probably a
different story yeah I'm not
my Raptor giant car would have [ __ ]
this car poppy would hit me but I honked
the horn just so we I was like dude
you're about to hit me just give him a
heads up like you're about to hit me
that honk horn he goes parked his car
so there's red light above parked his
car gets out know where I'm I swear am i
no hits my hood oh goes get out
[ __ ] like oh god are you kidding
me so I get out and win the street and
it's by there's like restaurants and
stores so now people are like looking
and I can see some someone's like oh I
hear buzz like buzz or big brown so I'm
like well alright so they're definitely
in a film and fitting goes down that's
what's going through my head right now
yeah and he's I'm not five six um no the
wrong side of 200 oh no red in the face
so so a little chubby 40 show mid-40s
oh that's and I get out and I go what
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
man and he goes you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
honky right oh my hot date because
you're darting into traffic
you almost hit my truck man I'm trying
to be calm right that's a always try to
be calm always try go you darted in I'm
honking to give you awareness you don't
hit me
you're just try and get faster it's a
[ __ ] red light what do you care if
you get down it I don't care again I'm
honking cuz you're gonna hit my car man
and what are you gonna do do you have a
dick gun you have a gun do you have a
any weapon he was darling
what do you do what the [ __ ] and do
he goes I dare you to hit me
I dare you to hit me I go why would I
hit you and what if I takes that step
closer I'm like oh no he goes I did hit
me and he goes I'll sue the [ __ ] out of
you oh my god oh yeah I know you well
men I know you will I know I wouldn't
have a good day and then he gets back in
this guy's like you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
I think that [ __ ] scrub you need me
to be a car I would have come around the
other side and I would go like this I
would just get up neck close to his ear
and I'm day you know I'd do this and I'd
go hey bro he won't he won't hit you but
he will [ __ ] you if he wants why you is
what other [ __ ] people did because I
would like to see you take that guy and
just [ __ ] him a little detail like like
life's not going his way I can tell us
just holding back Tommy Bahama shirt on
is wrinkly interns going [ __ ] khakis
yeah he's in this rental he darts off i
honk yeah it's probably the seventh
frustrating thing that happened to him I
know and then I get out he's a god damn
it kid so I bet if I was smaller mmm and
I'm not even trying to shame it I bet if
you were to get out there Ben he was
looking for conflict yeah so when I go
do you have a gun like a bullet for
other giant get out he might be a bully
or just have an awful day in our past
decide to cross so when it's funny
because obviously physically he's not
gonna beat me that's just not in the
coin fake an injury ensue yeah so when I
get out and then it's kind of humorous
kill you do you have a gun and he was
gonna no weapon you just know it what do
you do I know we just stare at each
other yes he takes a step closer because
now there's an audience oh I came from
CBS I'm thinking maybe some of the big
execs are they're having lunch they see
oh there's that [ __ ] meat wow you're
gonna fight again I don't think they
would ever set just one yeah and I'll
just say I'll parent I was like oh god
here we go man tell you what do you do
and they take SEP closer cuz I think he
was embarrassed
cuz now offseason I can physically
assault me that's not in the cards for
him that's not the way this pecking
order works
so he's like alright well I can't just
get back to my car look like a [ __ ] so
he just he's real close goes I dare you
to hit me and I could just tell my god
dude
like don't Palace I want to be like you
want to fake like you hit me and then
I'll like get back in my car so you can
save face what do you want to do then I
know like what do you want to do man did
I go what are you doing us oh I was like
oh that's what's wrong with this town
this is such a bummer man he's just not
really he can't back it up I don't know
I just felt bad for him then he gets in
his car and he like darts off and you
tell you didn't want to take the right
but he wanted to get out because he's so
embarrassed so he goes all right where
it's just death stop traffic and then I
pull up so I can stay like now or window
to window just like isn't it waiting
lady you're fearful yeah it's a parking
lot yeah the only time I've ever dude
and his face was so red just going
I'll sue the [ __ ] out of you the only
time I've ever done anything like that
where I was was I've had road rage
beyond was my child was really young and
in the backseat and this trucker was
tailgating me I mean on my ass would
have killed us all and I kept [ __ ]
and then finally I pulled alongside him
I'm trying to scream at him I'm giving
the fan I'm trying to get him to pull
over I was that angry I was that at home
the kids I was done but I was she's all
red and then I tried to fire if he stops
a truck stop like I went to all the
calculations I go I'm just gonna come
out of it too I'm just gonna come at him
I'm knocking and I'm not gonna even warm
it's gonna hit me back and then take all
that all the penalties this truck is
made tough [ __ ] yes but also my
child you know I know but some of those
truckers you know monk losing the
Marines will get them anytime some more
that's fine but in other words sometimes
sometimes that doesn't matter yeah
sometimes you're like you're tough it
that it's also kind of stupid though
when you add your age of no say it
stupid am I like even when I got back to
my truck I'm like I should just stayed
in my [ __ ] truck obviously the guys
tiny looks like Danny DeVito
but fatter and uglier listen yeah when I
get out let's say he did have a gun I
got a kid what's the questionnaire or am
i doing the other kind of like oh god I
can't read what my daughter's funniest
thing I was like you have a gun that
made me my two kids are in the backseat
I probably told you this and the guy I
pulled out same thing there's this car
wash and the guy goes you and your [ __ ]
said the f-word actually but let's just
say both you and your [ __ ] Tesla [ __ ]
you [ __ ] and I love her with your kid
they my daughter my somewhere in
backseat because you own a car wash beat
you didn't tell me no no I was I was I
was I was pulling up to a stoplight look
and I didn't let him get in I did I just
didn't see him so he was trying to pull
in to get in line I just didn't see him
I you and your [ __ ] your buzzy F were
that is fresh yeah yeah I just say [ __ ]
f-word you called me the f-word oh oh
just hit yes I was like it's a [ __ ]
yeah but also yeah so yeah y'all so when
you drive a test like I know what you
get well that's what he said right I
gotta close when I had and think one of
my tests was white I now
nightblood stuff you know I got the
midnight blue now now guys go that guy
looks like he's got hands oh well not
another thing oh not no okay
so that but now when they see me they
got that's the guy with don't don't
that's the guy with a trunk full of Uggs
no trunk full of hugs and tennis rackets
I do have tennis rackets but no Uggs
when I sit I look down I go like I sucks
what [ __ ] no no no well okay but the
bottom line is my dog and I looked and
you know how that is you get challenged
and your mind goes right you're like
your thing maybe I'll you know just for
a second oh maybe I go and then my
daughter said my daughter and I think
this time I think this exactly said she
went 11 years old she goes dad don't
respond oh wow from the backseat my 11
year older mature than both of us that's
correct service my blind let me know dog
knew and saw everything and I was like
I'm so proud of her yeah that's and then
the guy I didn't say anything I just
look and the guy goes you buzzing baby
and you know if you just go like this if
it's just like that's how I do it I do
if you just go sorry dude they're like
[ __ ] I'm never getting out of my car to
fight over our traffic I don't give a
[ __ ] it's very strong I don't scare
best-case scenario nothing there's no no
upside again the only time I've ever had
like in the last [ __ ] seven years the
one time I've had real like straight-up
serial killer rage was I was at Century
City Mall in the parking lot there's a
nightmare and this old dude and his wife
I mean I wait it's a crosswalk they're
far away speeds up and comes this close
to hitting me my son I have my mm-hmm
yeah that's what happens that's what I
got so upset yeah Joanna's never see me
like that yeah I was like take tiger I'm
about to kill to perón's well they
always say that daddy's going to prison
so so I'm the Jared Diamond who wrote
that book comes terms and steal diamonds
a lot of diamonds
they say they OPI say what book should I
read how is it you can start with Guns
Germs and Steel want to pull it surprise
it's about butcher that you bail out
they recommend to me you it's a lot of
work it's
it's a little boy it's all dry yes it's
like he did a lot of study with
indigenous cultures in Papua New Guinea
cultures that had very little contact
with the outside world cannibals
cultures that practice Widow strangling
so when you're their husband dies they
strangle the next of king strangling all
these really weird cultures way up in
the highlands and and tribes that have
been isolated for forty thousand years
and and he said that there's a lot of
times tribes will be really peaceful all
of them had wrote know they'll be
peaceful and everything else when
resources go get scarce and when say
there isn't enough water and their kids
their children are rather yet they get
Jenna Seidel he said that what they'll
do is to justify their their attacks
kill the dog he'll start coming up with
stories yeah that's what he grew up with
look at this no not him no I mean that's
what I know that's what he that's what
he can't pull that back but that's what
he was around he was around those people
and he set off to see where why why
civilization why all these inventions
happen in Europe and not anywhere else
and it's a really interesting book about
that but inroads into but he said we
said that human beings what as soon as -
were all nice we all talked about peace
as soon as our children attend I don't
have a night to eat or drink we will
kill those people over there and that's
he said these are all gonna be if it's
my kids surviving or you you're gonna
kill you've gotta kill me.unfortunately
that's you gotta kill - bummer if you
had a truth looking you ain't Tiger and
me you're gonna like what do you think
Tiger but without even without a
question that's what happened like no
not him [ __ ] you killed Brian dude
dammit
or say Brian girls man well but I don't
like what you see what you just did now
I want to stop you I know you're a tough
guy
I know epic see we did you you're
discounting you're discounting the fact
that I got hands dude I'm peppering your
face pop pop pop pop pop pop hum yeah
dude and go on your body
yeah it should a strange traffic will
[ __ ] get yeah speaking of sin your
DNA so finally the matter of that story
we should wrap it up is to always kill
each always attack for always home
attack first we talk your horn and yep
carry a weapon and use it don't worry
about the movies yeah the
destroyed make sure you carry a gun
because if someone was then as nice as I
was you might have problems but you're
better off taking the punch and having a
lawyer in your back seat and videotaping
everything on your dashboard and then
you get lots of money
yeah people had their phones up I was
like you know this isn't gonna go well
then no matter what that's the one good
thing about that's actually I think one
of the good things about everybody
having cameras on their phones people
are way less willing to do some crazy
[ __ ] well that that's why I guess like
hit me yeah cuz he knows I can't you
know I think though in states where
you're allowed to carry guns
I believe that homicides are higher yes
in alterations that right yeah it's a
problem yeah I got a little problem with
that yeah what can you do
I'm speaking of just natural DNA I
finally connected Bobby Lee and did
their podcast like Tiger belly yeah
that's yesterday do you hear Santino and
Bobby Lee going bad on me
no it's hilarious on their podcast yeah
bring it up on Fighter indicated website
he's firing the kid website
firing a kid dad instrument oh there are
YouTube I think it was instant pussycat
yeah somebody did I believe it was the
fake inning that's my uh which one is it
that one the middle one this is Bobby
Lee and Santino on tiger belly I think
it was on Santino shows um oh he had
okay he was worse and more stuff than he
was good in that's how I'll say about
Brian I don't say that he is bad and
more stuff that he was good and stuff
extended twice right yeah don't say that
out loud thought Bryan Callen I said it
once I'll say it a thousand times if he
wants to fight we can set it up you you
know that I could stop your heart right
I always forget though he's like 70 52
and I use this it's 83 alright
he does things well he'll send me videos
and he'll just do going around he sends
me red dress all the phrase and I wanna
go and kill him because of yeah yeah he
thinks he's funny
goodnight
so it's bleach media not the favorite
[ __ ] yeah so with uh with so that I
would they do it out of Bobby's house
mmm like they live upstairs I get you
care all Bobby's Bobby's just waking up
let me down I'm like it's wonderful
that's annoying Tim it's one
clock yeah yeah so anyways finally did
their show which I supposed to do a long
time and his girl died me dime he knows
this oh yeah die me die evolved swimmer
I don't think swimmer yep
but where do you give out our athletic
achievements cuz but we talked about
that when we did the podcast yeah did
your athletic well she's in athletic
she's a big athletic cow and she's with
Bobby who's not a big athletic guy that
we're saying she's so attractive to
offices and this is where I'm telling
with this thing is yes so we are talking
about attractiveness and she goes well
you know whether about you know Bobby's
date supermodels before and the reason
we connected because of our
personalities I want hold on hold on I
want I will promise you this
kyla right kalila kalila I would said I
will promise you just kalila if you
didn't look that way you guys would not
be here you might in this just the way
it works like attraction initially is
the way you guys connected then if you
guys vibe then there's usually a four
along relationship but if you didn't
look like that and you would even have
the opportunity for you guys divided and
because that's the only way the only
thing that's gonna track this off the
bat yeah is that physical attraction if
he wants to go well you gotta look
deeper than the skin no I get that it's
in my DNA to be attracted to my tie
that's right so as soon as I meet
someone if I'm attracted to him
physically alright check that dicks hard
and then you talk to him and then if
they're got a personality then you move
them in have kids but we're not even
gonna get to that phase if you don't
check the other box they did a study and
I camera where it was but it was pretty
comprehensive and they looked at all
these long-term couples that have been
together for a long time and they said
what is the main sort of source and all
of them said a deep sexual connection
that that seemed to have last
interesting yeah I mean I do think a lot
of relations like complete bullsh yeah
it was yes jay-z's like I'm so sick of
[ __ ] Beyonce I don't think so I think
every guy in the world eventually it may
be so but that's true but you still are
drawn to the person like you
I disagree some people are dependent and
they stopped far I think the physical
thing goes out the window eventually so
there was more about like you being able
to kind of Co live with each other and
operate that's that's a different thing
they were looking at relationships that
still had that were still going really
strong where they spent a lot of time
together okay I think I disagree with
that yeah well I think I think it's more
I know what this like when you have your
best friend because it doesn't matter
who you are yeah a venture you get sick
of [ __ ] yeah you need to eventually
get sick a [ __ ] that or driving that
Bentley or a Ferrari like you get used
to it and it's just like all right
whatever
well you can't see your life without
them right because the relationship
takes on a whole different dimension
yeah if you base it just offsets you're
[ __ ]
yeah you can't do just but but yeah but
just some theatres will stay I think
it's still you still need to be
physically attracted to the person for
sure but you wouldn't like it can't be
oh that's my point yeah you're not even
get in the you know you get on the front
door yes basically they don't check the
box this is what I heard a good stat
they said sorry is that if the sex is
bad it's 95 percent of the relationship
if the sex is good it can be 10 percent
of the relationship yeah so in other
words you know it's saying but if it's
bad you're you're yeah yeah they're
great though their whole team's really
good the producers hilarious pretty I
think he's Korean chin because I go hey
what's up what do you do hop in and he
no not Bobby but listen up when I talk
about seeds to produce it he's this
Korean dude but he's Filipino is he do
you know because I go what are you Rob
and he goes I'm just he's on their
Instagram there he goes I'm like he goes
I'm just like chin that guy's fella I
think he means like he's just like chin
as a producer not necessarily I think
because we look kind of similar keeps
going down wow this is where I get my
agents wrong Rumble this is Bobby's
Instagram when we go there actual tiger
belly no you'll see I thought I saw him
keep going wasn't he
I saw him when you're scrolling unless I
was a different one Bobby so painfully
if there he is so the middle one there
is far left
yeah that's Filipino Wow might even be
Thai one of those time was the guy in
the middle no idea Oliver Hudson
oh that's Kate Hudson and uh Carrie what
the hell's guys a lot s key from Holly
Kurt Russell chapter son I think oh wow
what's he do is an actor I think he's
not you huh handsome guy that's cool
yeah he's handsome he's all opponents
Russell's one other cost me and Jimmy
Burke had a long talk with him when used
on the street I was a [ __ ] cool guy
he's a male yeah tombstone he's just
doing general that's right he was into
amazing tombstone skate from New York
he's my generation so Cobra mmm do you
really need a wife beater and a
cigarette with glasses on
well Cobra was you know Cobra was right
that's right those slicer that's right
oh no big trouble little Charlie thing
in a tango and cash nope tango look at
movies hang on cash was cross-eyed for
me boy I thought Cobra was Russell bring
up bring up Cody trouble big trouble
little China's top five oh look at that
he just run around the beater really
couldn't fight needle guns he's he had
such a sense of humor his strength was
he was so hilarious on that yeah he's
great in that yeah tango and cash he was
just so [ __ ] good in that man yeah
he's great and then there and then there
daughters
Kate Hudson right yeah bring up how
cheesy killer Stallone is in Cobra and
Cobra he's bodied up in Cobra dude tango
& cash Kathy Ireland and tango & cash ah
ah yeah go to the cover though chin yeah
yeah that's it
yeah [ __ ] yeah don't [ __ ] with Cobra
pretty currying out now end the scene
member they go bring out the Cobra
couldn't find him and he just shows up
he gets out of his car he's got this
like it's so great just killing it crime
is the disease made occur
back then that's how they did it [ __ ]
yeah that's how they did it my
generation brat Jack Brack that's my
generation Oh bang Brigitte Nielsen oh
god I love it
oh I loved when she was on vh1's
celebrity house whatever the [ __ ] oh
yeah she and she [ __ ] French read her
and Flavor Flav do me a favor bring a
picture of Bridget and Allison Flavor
Flav Flavor Flav you hated deep and true
he ran deep and true he's got a I don't
care how small he is you've seen how
small he is in life right yeah look at
still got a piece on him
she looks mentally all right are they
dating a disaster I don't think are they
still gate no really I know I don't know
where they really having sex
oh yeah did she talk about on the show
they were like [ __ ] together and they
argue all the time cuz they they went on
the show right fell in love they were
all in there went they went on couples
like therapy and [ __ ] if I would flame
what a character that what a difference
in size Bridget Nelson Jost but you know
she could been the game of Thrones
hooker a piece what he's won think when
she was younger Brigitte Nielsen had
something to say sir well for sure she
had something to say yeah she has some
say now it's just nobody coherent she
did she find her way into some
substances yeah I forgot her in sly dude
yeah dude dude think about the [ __ ]
there was some stuff going on
think about the boom Danni Sylvester
Stallone took down he took down some he
was that was back in the day when movie
stars were royalty where you were
royalty and you did one grandmother
[ __ ] and didn't get fired too
you did what and when was she doing out
there you knew Brigitte Nelson currently
she's an older woman now no but she was
haven't oh yeah that's right she had a
baby at 55
the actress welcomed her daughter Frieda
On June 3 55 the new 30s there's a lot
less appointment I think I think the
chances a mom owns the chance of Down
syndrome if you have a child that's how
are you
sup like crazy but good for her man
she's a Mon it's cool five kids is a
full-time job
well the other ones like 30 and 40 but
yeah oh they're yeah they're super old
okay yeah still a job still a pain it
would be tough if your mom was [ __ ]
Flavor Flav and you're 22 years old
mmm the big tough go mmm like really all
right yeah hmm when chosen Creed - OH
Flavor Flav Sean was a horrible what did
she say ran it back was agree - what did
she say about
oh she's Drago's wife the best strong
was a horrible let me say what's it say
there it's gonna be a video United
States films really I was he I did was
physically looking at them they're
bigger than life but that's why Dennis
Miller got this interview
he's a smart woman it's called this
interview obviously Jumeirah still oh oh
was it that bad yes how did you get
along with him on Creed - then it's out
and because he's a pro I'm a pro and we
do to him she looks like people
internationally it's a big girl we
buried the hatchet we moved on which is
what human heard John said never miss a
beat
well she's really talking now she's
listening when they do when they're
young he's probably slinging dick all
over this course coming on all the walls
didn't give a [ __ ]
then she get off well huh what are you
havin a good time bro did you just say
coming on all the walls I don't
understand what that means
tango & cash dude no but you know what
I'm saying no not really busy
yeah it's spring - rocky bros leaving
his mark in every room yeah okay like
yes um yeah that wasn't too bad she's
like she was just being honest
of course how was Larry King it was
great with Dennis Miller he's brilliant
so it was really cool though because for
me because I grew up watching Dennis
Miller in fact when I watched I went to
a taping of Saturday Night Live at 19 or
whatever and he was the star basically
Dennis man I remember these three
[ __ ]
beautiful gals looking back on it they
were professionals they're professional
hot girls and but I was like you know I
was young males like these are the
hottest girls I've ever seen and they
just kept trying to catch a glimpse of
him they were just in love with him and
I was like a comedian so to be on
Saturday Night Live
and to be that and that in a lot of ways
and then I'm listening to him introduce
me and I'm doing their King lion-o I was
like this morning this is yesterday at
Wednesday and I was like this is crazy
this is this is like full circle like
it's it's kind of marquise 65 and tired
well we talked about that he said did i
I've spent my life on sets and working
and I haven't really seen much they said
so I want to start doing things like
going to Italy oh well you know maybe
hanging out on a working olive oil farm
or whatever and I was like I get it I
get it all the way and then Kevin Nealon
was there Kevin Nealon yeah I went to
whatever just like going to Tuscany okay
seeing how people live but Kevin Nealon
was there so now I'm with Kevin Nealon
and Dennis Miller and they want as a
building and I and I'm with these two
beasts and Kevin Nealon is I've never
met anybody who can be funny all the
time not stop he's one of those people
that I kind of marvel at how talented he
is all the time but they were just
catching up and it was just I don't know
I'm at 202 legends so it was on yeah all
legend so it was on Larry King show
though yeah he was filling in yeah he
took care yeah he took over it was
really fun then it was that well II and
my dude Larry King leave a heart attack
yeah and it stopped but then like no
he's coming back he's just be just on
the mend CNN killer es ahora and it's on
Hulu now we give you originally I think
that the mile on track was up and then I
think I don't know their price like dude
you're he's 85 he's older yeah he's
still pretty far down there too yes I've
seen that yeah yeah I love it it's holy
I mean when you're that age like that's
matter dude doesn't matter but it enjoys
old he's just still doing it still doing
it man yeah departure on June 2010 king
of 25 years they'd be stepping down
there you go what a great show though
yeah his ticker he's gonna bomb dinner
right now and that's what happens when
you're 85
yeah and he just had right he came out
of surgery yeah yep
so and he's on the mend and that's cool
man yeah that must been a cool
experience yes really I was listening to
Howard Stern yesterday and if you get so
Howard Stern's channel 100 he had Dana
Carvey on he was amazing yeah but he had
a heart problem that's why I took him
now he's out now he's getting healthy
though yeah his heart's good so good but
they if you go to the station 101 they
do his like old hits they had Howard
Stern from 1985 playing his radio
station 85 plan Wow soul said that I
said Stern 85 David Letterman her
parents there's his first time jumping
on Letterman but was Letterman in 85
didn't make sense to me this madman
letter most 85 was he mm-hmm
Letterman was my senior I graduated high
school in 85 oh so he was talking about
this yeah it looks dude I forget like
when I went when it was said uh Stern
1985 I'm like that dudes been doing this
that long yeah I go that's why they call
him the king of media he's been doing it
longer than 85 and it's so interesting
why he got fired in Washington DC in
Washington DC in 1980 yeah I mean it was
really early
he said the this a plane crashed into
the Potomac right where the 14th Street
Bridge was laying or used to say no no
it crashed it was a tragic thing yeah he
called the airline and asked how much a
ticket costs from Washington National to
the 14th Street Bridge and they were
like you are off the air and what's
interesting about him when you listen
those 19 those real old-school ones so
Robins still there she was with him from
day one but it's so crazy cuz they you
know they're worth I built you know
basically a billion dollars together now
they're so rich the dynamic hasn't
changed at all right like I went from 85
and I listened to the interview with
Dana Carvey I'm like holy [ __ ] through
this theme it's the same vibe he still
has the same attitude even though look
at the whole that whole crew skills
relevant to that's really hard to do
with the podcast but I agree but also he
you can hear back then how he's just
talking [ __ ] on how they're like man
they should let you host David Letterman
he's like they [ __ ] should and he's
kind of ahead of time but even before
pakka
I went produce that [ __ ]
overproduced how real conversation like
what would you do if they had it like
Sylvester slowing just I'll talk about
him [ __ ] girls that's what we all
want to hear man they're all like
laughing and yeah he's such a beast yes
yes that's exactly right he used to
always ask uncomfortable questions
memory used like the fart man bear
ammonia an empty bean had his ass out no
bring that I do remem CD outran MTV
Awards where chapters the fart man he's
wearing assless chaps and he's not young
to remember this that stuff right
imagine imagine when when was that 19
month 92 it says there and that's when
he was on ye remember he got his he was
his show was huge on e look he had like
naked chicks and strippers all the time
yes look at this guy he's so big man
he's a big boy because when you go to
New York you do the serious hit now
Stern hasn't his own his entire own
floor like they used to share it and I
just has his own [ __ ] yeah he's
hilarious man
cuz that he has a book coming out he's
been doing his own he's been doing all
this media stuff he's like Gus he's like
this is really mad cuz it really helps
he's like my fans are gonna buy the
books but the reason you do these other
things is because you think like fans
outside your box are in a bite he's like
he's the only buy a book that says
Howard Stern is coming on you he's like
that's the title of the book something
like that coming coming again or
something right he's like you know I
have my fans and they love it but it's
really for them yeah he's like when I go
on the viewing speak here I went on the
ice when he has he makes 300 million a
year cuz it's anyone really gonna buy
the book oh my god that's hilarious
how ridiculous is they do that that's
amazing he just eats just crazy man John
Stamos good old John and that was it
what year was that June 1992 Wow 92 fart
part man even now they still like I'm
like man I wonder when we'll grow up
he's all them both of us be the snot
show surrounded by other grown-ass
adults Erwin's 50 60 years old
like idiots oh my god yeah Robin to say
something like I wonder what she ate for
dinner in back and then it was like
these sounds and then Howard's a cabbage
you blew up the bathroom like these guys
are awesome
I'm Eric and he's always talkin about
[ __ ] he's like but you know what's
weird is he has this weird talent where
he's worth whatever four hundred million
dollars every year and these they
brought these kids on music how much you
guys make and they're like you know
whatever like you know we're making good
money we don't have to work you're like
God that must be so great man I wish I
got into that should I get into that
business it's like are you talking about
but he's still like he doesn't ever drop
the guard of Alba Richie is yeah I marry
I get this [ __ ]
I was also think about this probably the
hardest show to get on oh yeah
what cuz I was talkin my Showtime PR guy
and I said you know what'd be the
hardest interview in the world to get on
here's what I want Howard Stern now it's
such a big audience and he's kind of
like Rogan where unless you kinda have
it in or he's interested in what you're
saying yeah you're not gonna get on
unless he like knows you personally or
you find something you did really funny
you're not getting on the Howard Stern
yeah same with Rogan you're not getting
the two biggest shows in the world
you're not getting on hmm like sometimes
I'll talk to Jamie about the some of the
they got the people Rogen's turned down
and you would lose your mind oh yeah you
got I'm sure what that'd be a dope inner
like and like any Tonight Show would be
foaming at the mouth for these guest
Rosen's like I don't have nothing to
talk to I'm not interested in what
they're doing
yeah dude that's crazy famous like
actors and stuff you mean uh a fleets
and actors yeah well because they're
glad the names liked it really yeah I
feel like that'd be awesome you not into
your pride is no doubt much to say to
them you know he's what he's just I
understand what they're doing yeah it's
he's on events though which is pretty
cool
mm-hmm Howard Stern same thing you're
not getting on there unless you know it
teeth creme de la creme
yeah I'll put you on the after show I'm
doing that they're they after me the app
Strunk my ego I'm gonna wait if I'm
thinking Afghan Howard someday we've
done that show together yeah
I think I'm doing that in New York for
my press tour good guys I like this guy
great guys yeah it's a pretty decent
bone look at Donald the Donald might
well you don't tension about endued
you're you're doing the same thing be is
with specials like there's no more like
just focus on one night one time only
yeah a year-long promotion yeah man like
I like because my special complicated
ape starts streaming June 12th so where
was it on Amazon so right now you can
rent or buy it right - on in any
platform but now it's gonna start
streaming on Amazon so everybody has
Amazon right so anybody who has Amazon
like Amazon Prime you can stream it it's
like so then you gotta push that enough
yeah cuz my yeah with Showtime because
obviously they're still traditional
media so eard Friday night at 7:00 yeah
push that push that push that you can
watch it for free well now it's on
demand yeah and then their data they
collect it for the whole year
yeah because so I did I did all of New
York last week
all our friends podcasts and then I did
Bobby Lee's yesterday and then I'll do
Rogan tomorrow and I told Justin
Showtime like then I'm done man
like I'm exhausted yeah I'm sick of
talking about this yeah like excuse me
yeah well no no no no because people can
watch because with Showtime it's not
just on TV they're on demand yeah you
can get it whenever you can keep
reminder cameras yeah yeah because
people to me I'm like go and then it
obviously with Showtime because they
want subscriptions which they got but
it's like best what's best case for me
is if you did that did that then
released it on YouTube yeah but no don't
work that way no they keep you on your
platform everybody's competing for to
get P subscribers yeah everyone
including us it's like this the holes
the way the hole of the game is yeah
it's so interesting how much it's
changed to the point where the movie
star as you know it is basically gone
who's a movie star there I can count
well you look they were just on a red
carpet Brad Pitt Gabrielle yeah there
you go that's it not a lot not a lot now
people Gershon bail would you put him in
there no not really
when you guys
for like a blockbuster yeah I don't know
isn't that amazing our DiCaprio and
[ __ ] Brad Pitt I Pitt but here's that
even that now it's about you it's about
Batman spider-man I don't give you it's
like that's right and not be you could
play spider-man that thing's gonna do
great that's right it's a it's a it's
the character spider-man if you play
Batman you do just as good as me and
Bale played at me put you put your flat
Christian Bale it's my uniform
it's the admins that sell in these days
wait I and was interesting because uh
James Corden who's on he they're so
fascinating because he's on late-night
and he's on that the 1 a.m. spot sir
Monday through Friday so that's a
terrible time slot yeah but guess what
his team said well it's not about the
time slot this is just the what the
wrong will shoe a shoe in there know
what yeah we're gonna shoot it there now
and we know the ratings aren't great cuz
yeah our Dan was not staying up to 1:00
a.m. so what we're gonna do is create
the best content possible and get the
biggest hit on YouTube yeah so now on
YouTube he crushes everybody else
destroys everyone digitally but then in
the Ray house his one am but his team
went no no let's just get our fun the
door that keep looking up well take that
time slot that really goes yeah yeah cuz
we got ideas for weird and what did i do
they just they just put out carpool
karaoke they have whole segments on it
yeah they have a new segment you know
they're just constantly coming up with
with have you guys hey if you guys heard
of up rocks I'm supposed to do an
interview with them I'm gonna help rocks
up rocks
it's got it they say it's got like a
subscription basis of 10 million unique
magazine I just I've seen their
Instagram before like their post cool
[ __ ] they seem cool be write articles
from their TV for current events we pull
some up rocks yeah and like I think
sometimes I'll see like yeah breaking
news and I'll see their tag on there
okay supposed to do a feature article on
them ah promotion can't hurt ya I'm just
worried buddy complicated apes
you'd be surprised get it get it the
time that sounds fantastic
I guess did die rich you do Aladdin no
did he go back one go back one
your Aladdin nostalgia so maybe he's
you're saying when you see it it's
different i wreck i Ricci was on bro is
fantastic him in a suit in here oh well
what you did it wasn't John fender up
dinner
Wow I had no idea that's interesting hey
do you have the Paulie Malignaggi stuff
on Kern events no but I can pull it up
did you see what he did he's sitting
artem space Oh Paulie is a volatile
fella
yes love the dude yeah but he's there he
gets sir press conference it's getting
interesting they [ __ ] hate each other
man well I think it's all that Connor
[ __ ] right there is a doctor yeah but
it's just like to spin another man's
faith well then what is actually round
fight there nothing does it matter
I don't know if round two it's
bare-knuckle I don't kind of interested
in the same I would watch it for chair
for Paulie so Brooklyn and Italian not
spitting just that no no you know he
booked him on the head T with a
microphone who did
Paulie Baba's Artem okay well no
spitting guys yeah hey spleen no sir
it's gonna strange but the thing I bet
this thing just pretty well like
everyone is kind the buzz is kind of
when the animosity is that real Jesus
how much is the papery for him the
promise is that they're their owner that
he's kind of a tool
yeah where he's like you know we're
deducting this fight purse because he
decided not to fight that's what we do
here it's like God who define who he was
to fighters and like they didn't rip
each other's heads off so he's like he
grabbed the mic this guide the promoter
he goes I want everyone know he's
kidding he's not getting paid he's
really don't do that here and the crowd
was like excuse me and started building
him and then online he got destroyed by
all of us come well that was the guy he
didn't perform one fighter was actually
running away he didn't perform all and
he was telling the audience like we
don't do that here in Barron Elko so he
says he's gonna give part of that salary
or whatever his purse to the other guy
so taken away from him we give him to
change the contract yeah yeah just on
the get fly $29.99 okay I'm at by it no
that's that's the old one chick I think
that's that
artim that was well against uh he's done
this before
Diaz yeah he fought just recently in his
face get and the other guy's face got
super [ __ ] up Jesus that is a rough
it's a tough ego right rough
it's got to be very different boxing
wise too because you don't have that you
don't have that extra glove man hard to
you know the protection is just a
different game for poly
I mean poly should wane off sees a world
champion yeah but you know what bare
knuckles a different animal man well
we're you can watch it on dish all right
now now is there anything on the hands
or it's completely bare knuckle do yeah
yeah we all fine
enjoy that yeah that hard time finding a
doctor that would because the cuts are
so bad in their face cuz no one really
wins in a bare-knuckle fight yeah swish
Franco's decision because the cuts are
so bad remember when Rogan Eddie and you
guys were like especially Roman Eddie
Reich I win a football field it was not
beer knuckle I'm like that doesn't work
dude that's not it's not gonna work well
when it went so so with um the amateur
boxing now when you're trying to get the
Olympics okay so you don't use headgear
the problem is people get cut so when
you're in the tournament to try to get
to just more no problem well the booster
cuts are a major problem cuz when you
don't have headgear you guys have cut so
the real yeah and all that stuff so guys
get cut and what happens is they they
don't go go on if they pull out yeah so
stupid it is you're not really seeing
the best fighter see my watch is Polly
fight I will - when is this listen June
22nd Saturday Tampa yeah the doctor came
to my show because they can't a lot of
place they can't get sanction because
the doctors don't because the cuts are
so bad it's so much work they don't want
to get he says the commissioners will
deal with crystal even is fighting you
fought before as well Brendan ward I
don't know do we know how much these
guys even paid have they denounced me
like her statement if Chris Levin's got
the biggest hands big his head and a
head he's just but his hands his fingers
are so [ __ ] thick I was December
there's one thing I noticed his head how
wide it is and how big his hands are so
he should probably be doing bare-knuckle
I don't know if anyone should be doing
better Garcia is that the liner Garcia a
volt yep wow that's great damn I think
it was like 40,000 last time I checked
no [ __ ] yet paid yeah
that's the bare-knuckle Oh No yeah Oh
what the [ __ ] is going on here who's
that guy
trainer or something and I'm depressed
all right that is that is just
Jason Nights a monster - his name is the
kid - huh look at heart of man what the
[ __ ] dude you know I like to heart him
to actually really good - guy
I'll say Pauly's my boy I want Pauly to
win I just you know I just feel like for
Pauly here's one of the most exclusive
hardest jobs in the world to get from
being a high-level box so good gonna
commentate on Showtime so good and he's
bright you just don't want to see him
you want to see him fight anymore
it just doesn't make sense cuz you're
set like guys would cut off their
[ __ ] left legs getting your I think
he just really loves the game I watched
him I watched him at glove works he
comes in now and I was watching him work
with Michael Ian and some other guys and
he's so passionate about it like he just
loves the strategy the game the way he
talks to guys who are in the ring there
it's like I think he's just in love with
the science of the of this yeah but that
doesn't mean you have to do bare-knuckle
boxing yeah but that's at the same time
the he's just a [ __ ] petition he's a
[ __ ] fighter and he just you know
right I mean yeah some people just can't
let it go yeah yeah so I don't know
Jason I says I'm we're making more in
bare-knuckle boxing what if he's singing
the same tune after he [ __ ] it must be
a lot of gambling on this and maybe they
get a purse of that a piece of that
somehow gambling yeah we're from the
movie Lion Heart no they they don't they
don't get a percent of gambling money
well is there where were these held or
AMPA there's one and they tried - are
they on reservations are they on because
if they are then then you could figure
out a way to work that out
the
15,000 of to fight me so as for alarm
every day's make it 50,000 to fight me
he put out there that he's making six
figures in three fights oh yeah begins
50 grand three five three hundred fifty
sir not great
well I like I'm not I don't plan on
going out there having a slugfest well
that's what you doing bring up the
buckling this is before so yeah our case
that's hilarious
oh no yeah I don't go out there fine I
have a Slugger somebody crazy we have
bare knuckles well that's well it's
exactly definitely yes well that's why
you're there in it
geez you've yeah there's no heavyweights
in this the big boys like [ __ ] that
noise wow I don't know man hmm I prefer
boxing
yeah we're MMA for the fighters I'm
gonna make more in bare-knuckle busting
in my last UFC fight not if you won but
do you have seniors go away with that
that's what I don't want get in this but
that you're seniors get away with the
wind and show and win money especially
now with the game revenue from ESPN well
like these guys gonna make a guaranteed
whatever 50 grand which is terrible but
guaranteed 50 grand to fight yeah no I
don't think there's any show on when neo
C should be you get paid regardless
because you're fighting and they're
getting view or ship off your fighting
skills whether you win or lose those
same amount of people are tuning in yeah
so you should get a flat fee because you
have C's get a flat fee now from ESPN ah
so the wind the width the when they
dangle that wind bonus
yeah make sure you win make sure we give
you a bonus if you perform well we get a
buck that's so silly yeah
no they're paying what they're worth
because you're getting the views no
matter what they do you're getting views
did you get the numbers on rose roses
last byte awful awful
yeah we don't three of them's were like
the record loaf since they've been with
the SPN it's been a nightmare but again
it's people are trying to adjust to it
they jump digital before anyone else so
it'll get there yeah yeah for the
prelims so so UFC 236 they say they
thought a hundred it's more like 70 is
what I'm hearing
Wow just low you know people but here's
the other thing so when that says lowest
in ESPN air and 70,000 pay-per-view buys
price 7 million illegally streamed it 7
line okay I would assume a few mulatto
games a lot so it's still getting out
there but not yeah yeah I don't know
yeah there's some Kurt events dude let's
should I depress yeah yeah it's not
about serial killers no okay so last
year the NYPD had a warrant to enter
somebody's apartment it was this woman's
and they came in because they believed
that her grandson was a part of a
illegal deal and that he was selling I
believe it was guns so they came in and
they said that they had guns and drugs
in the apartment they looked around
found a couple of vials that you can see
her holding right here her husband's
ashes are actually inside I thought it
was easy mistake to mention kind of
creepy but lashes in there so yeah cops
I like what the [ __ ] right yeah yeah and
so they got got confiscated because they
they're testing them for drugs and it
hasn't been revealed whether there were
any drugs found inside of them but
according to the woman she says that her
husband before he passed wanted a piece
of him to be with his wife his son and
his grandchildren and that's why they're
in little vials like that and right now
the family's just in the process of
trying to get those vials back so they
can have a piece of their loved one
again kind of creepy and sweet that's
all creep also a good way to hide your
drugs I mean little bullet yeah my cool
intentions yeah yeah BP sweet as you get
so do you remember the story about blac
chyna getting accepted into Harvard
there's a bunch of people doing that so
Sierra just announced yesterday that she
got accepted into Harvard Harvard
Business School as well
really now we don't know whether or not
it's the same thing that block china was
doing we would have I should have seen
it similar yeah
older celebrities who like got into
Harvard yeah did you wait would you
you've been studying where how the [ __ ]
you in the Harvard don't believe I know
artists in the Harvard I got some
skeptical I'm skeptical
and then and then so she's went straight
from high school look never been a
college but always dreamt of going to
college but by God's grace don't bring
God into this by God's grace my music
career took me on a path that it I'm so
thankful for this week
I got accept him to Harvard yeah I am
hold up after 30 years yeah she going to
Harvard she says that she is going to be
attending Harvard she doesn't specify
whether that means an online course or
if she's gonna be actually on campus hmm
so there aren't too many details but I
thought this was interesting because of
the whole blac chyna thing good for her
though Oh doctor I saw blac chyna really
weird I forgot when I did Breakfast Club
dad talked about this to you chin blow
the belt yeah I saw when I was a black
breakfast club I got them waiting I'm
waiting for everyone and wait for
Charlemagne and Charlene comes in and
goes dude sorry man
we're just running late we had [ __ ]
blac chyna come I didn't know she was in
come on it blac Chyna's in there and so
me and Andrew or they're sitting there
with Jay and I'm like yeah I'd love to
get a look at that man I mean she pretty
and the introduced I'd love to get a
look do as we're going up Andrew goes
dude she's gonna see you your best case
Rob Kardashian you look just like him
races yeah like she's gonna dig you saw
Mike hell yeah so we walk in died me
dime died me die me dying really yeah
yeah she was there promoting her new
show but she's on some new reality show
it's super hot really yeah not my type
me neither when you see this not my type
either in person I like damn there's
something about her yeah she looks a lot
better in this particular episode or
whatever know what she looks like
science got ahold of her
I don't care cheese all right she was
delicious hmm she's got pierced nipples
yeah you could tell him
oh she a freak sex videos awful see I
appreciate her sexy she ate her bad
being a freak
well now well freak it is all I
shouldn't say freak her sex video I'm
not very freaky when he comes she just
gooey don't get it on me
no oh hold on ma'am I'm jacking off to
cool on motor oh well that's a problem
guys she's [ __ ] you can't be all the
guy she's [ __ ] I'm not was the exact
same physique as the in the color as
those camera stands dark one dark man ah
this houses piece bad but he's very
skinny mm-hmm oh so she's so she
obviously got this thing out there we
can't tell I think was the guy because
it doesn't do any justice cuz people
were pissed all their to go to the
bottom right one you see how skinny is
looks like slender man skinny fella
she's bad as [ __ ] though and here's the
other thing she had those [ __ ] socks
on the couch if McGregor black Hanes
socks on yeah the whole time she's
[ __ ] a few and then when he comes she
goes oh no no don't get it on to it oh
[ __ ] dude gotta keep your gotta keep
your feet warm bro if you can still find
it on the money shot solders the money
shot came and she was like nah nah not
today not today
and they keep the kill get through those
other pictures gentleness gracious don't
I mean alright pretty great dude there
you go is that him
I don't think that dark not my guys more
light-skinned this guy's pretty dark she
had her butt done grabs his pieces
alright it's just okay it's just okay
let's open for more otherwise the whole
look at her sighs there's nothing least
sexy then have no socks on look at the
[ __ ] sock okay do it yeah did you
feed up it yeah she could be wearing
Baked hams on each foot I wouldn't give
a [ __ ] I beg ya to your size yeah your
your you put a pansy-ass in a detail
me I'd be like a half [ __ ] you got
baked hands on your feet maybe your feet
are jacked maybe she's got horrible hose
like boy yeah she may have like just
t-rex feet she might have just giant the
camel up there yeah great oh yeah there
you get the socks
she's so just great that's a great angle
for her it's sexy dude right that's a
flattering angle one attractive door now
I am in PE yeah well when you got away
said you know I saw a real thing in
person all right I'm with you then I'm
with you I got you that's like when I
was an ace Rob here's Rob I worked with
Pamela Anderson back when she was you
know Pamela Anderson and she would come
on set and that was like her and Jessica
Simpson back when they were like at
their height and I was like well you're
the hottest things family you look like
you're dipped in gold and their bodies
were crazy and they were crazy sexy of
course yes yes yes dude very woman
Electra very unique take oh the terrible
video but I watch it was the middle of
the day whatever yeah I like Kim K's he
was well produced yeah shout out to her
mom what else we get I think here so a
man in Santa Ana they say that he was a
teen because he was a teen last year
when he did this he broke into the Santa
Ana Zoo and he stole a lemur trying to
keep it as a pet oh yeah I have a couple
of those in the middle of the night he
actually put the lemur in a plastic
container wrote a sign on it saying
stolen from the Santa Ana Zoo please
return so he changed his mind he was
later caught because he was staying at a
hotel nearby and he is currently getting
charged the guy in DC zoo Washington DC
zoo when I was in college
stole two gaboon Vipers one bring up a
goblin the biggest Viper in the world
stole two gob une Vipers and they he was
on the bus he had him in a burlap sack
now they have the long-ago Everlong
Spanx of any [ __ ] snake look at how
big their Wolsey
so he can kill an elephant short enough
fat huh oh and there there holy that
better get some torch the fangs can go 2
inches long I barely got some torque eat
or do ya bit got that short fat dick yes
you know that from K large paper in the
world no you have you ever seen that oh
good
remember there's a documentary on HBO
it's it falls prostitutes there's a
series on HBO and me and my roommates in
college used to watch and there's
nothing funny this guy picks up this
[ __ ] you know prostitute or pro this
hooker and they were falling around this
black girl and it's like this you know
fat like white dude and she gets in as
and she's miked up and she gets in there
ages there she was ooh
because he like that she goes yes
subtitles so you can understand I said
this but you you got that short fat dick
never forget they got that gabumon Viper
a bit like I was like hey man don't want
this that ain't good it's not good well
so this thing bit him this kid through
the bag on the bus oh my god yeah and he
was paralyzed for life minimum ha he had
a strong storms back Milan Hey right
through the burlap sack back and he was
like ah I don't feel so good
don't feel so good yep and he's all he
was yeah he got paralyzed well we don't
want to [ __ ] he wasn't see a lot of
times well yeah I'm gonna steal a couple
gaboon viper doesn't even get him in the
bag teenage kid how do you give them in
the back so you can catch him you use
that there there's a yeah you're angry
[ __ ] that gaboon Vipers are I've never
seen a note gel snakes dude I was hiking
my dad yesterday and there's a snake on
the trail and I [ __ ] ran the other
direction my dad goes oh my god you're
scared of snakes I'm all who's not who's
nuts alright when I inserted I went my
bat Indiana Jones
yeah I'm little scared of [ __ ]
rattlesnake up yeah yeah
rattle snakes and vipers when they bite
you a rattlesnakes a Viper you don't
want to get bit by a Viper
look at that enjoy that when he stinks
those teeth into your lack buck and the
end and shoots a bunch of neurotoxin in
your about a cool animal
yeah dude how about I let Papa Saab take
the Viper out last night on the highway
he said he would've thought it was Lewis
Hamilton driving he's a car guy right
big car guy yeah big car guy let him
drive cuz I was like oh let's go get ice
cream so he can drive the car yeah where
he leave and he's like oh yeah no doubt
now you want to drive you guys yeah I've
had like a few glasses of wine bomb
goodbye Lana that's interesting okay
sure
take my car so I'm the driver's seat no
one I didn't would never let anybody
else drive it maybe my brother that's it
sure you I don't want you to looking at
it well I won't have let me I can't take
it for a spin not for you bro but I know
how to drive for you papa shop gets
behind the wheel yeah and you would have
thought they were filming fast and for
your seven really I had to go let's calm
down a tad dad really
yeah man so now you have to go Tiptronic
yeah Pat you have the the gear shifters
yeah do you use those oh yeah
so something but do you have to use em
or can you just drive it or not if you
just felt like if I was driving to work
today I just leave an automatic but when
I might get night
like last night driving back from
economy stores using the paddle shifters
oh that's what it's fun automatic it
could be any car off the line do you
beat me in off the line in the first go
to zero to sixty what Tesla edition you
don't have the 75 SD check zero 60 75 d
yes you I crush you really yours is so
the while the model 75 d got 0 to 60 and
4.9 seconds very cool go to fry f12 4.9
seconds what's it go what is it ff12
it's gonna be I think right at 3 1 3 D 1
don't go mmm this has all of them on
there Jesus you should be able to find
it weighs it you narrow down f12
something go P if we go 2018 or 2012
3.1 there you go 3.1 3.1 seconds 3.1
hold on yeah cuz the Loon occurs like a
9 the Ludacris gets to 9 so you're right
there with him
and I don't suck [ __ ] and wear Uggs now
he cool right hold on you gotta give it
up for the Ludacris I need to hear you
you got to take that back I told I told
Paul to Paul Joe we have the same
finance guys when I heard you get new
cars thought for sure you're gonna Tesla
all Mike you know it all plans to work
to do some you all got Tesla's I went
cuz they ain't [ __ ] Paul ain't [ __ ] if I
said if I ever get a Tesla fire me fire
me fire me love resistance same way as I
still have hotmail yeah [ __ ] with
hotmail yeah I refuse to change that's
amazing to me I refuse to change
it's amazing that you still have hotmail
I just realized that the brush my teeth
with coal yep all right next up next ill
drink diet coke come at me I drink diet
coke yeah this one says 2.8 seconds yeah
bottom line fastest luck
yeah ridiculous get your [ __ ] rotten
tomatoes anymore get your [ __ ] Tesla
out of my face bro well I told you had a
guy come to my show in Tampa who worked
for Tesla cuz hey VIPs don't a picture
quit talkin [ __ ] about Tesla what excuse
me quit talkin [ __ ] we're all essential
we're all fans of yours invest we're
talkin [ __ ] I went no doubt that's what
are you waiting in line to tell you use
nice about it though that's how oil is
I'm a big fan listen
quit talking sh about Tesla I work for
Tesla they're great man you don't need
to hate on them we listen the show don't
hate on us invest in the [ __ ] company
like no doubt dude I love it he's
walking on it you know what dude let me
get one he was really ha ha so there is
a hoodie that a 25 year old in San
Francisco made that's bulletproof so she
makes bulletproof hoodies and denim
jackets this is starting to make its
rounds or within the Internet and
Shannon Watts who runs a company against
him well she runs the organization I
believe it's mothers demand like more
gun reform something like that she
basically tweeted out of photo of the
hoodie with the Creator in it saying
that we don't have to live
this way and so this is just going viral
because we're getting to a point where
people are making clothes that are
bulletproof
yeah I won't catch on or maybe you will
Kevlar gloves not heavy it's gotta be
I'm not gonna life my kids going into
middle school some and it it looks the
same looks dope this doesn't look the
same because it's gotta be normal my
videos pretty happy though pretty heavy
heavy heavy made of Kevlar yeah they're
kinda what kind of rounds have looks
pretty light though
Kevlar can be light yeah gear for people
who never used to need the armor like
kids and teachers one search on Amazon
produces an entire list of items Fortran
witnessing her neighbor's brutal murder
was enough to change the trajectory of
her own career I looked online for some
trans a tough name these days but I
couldn't find anything really made for
women or children science could be worse
your last name could be ho yeah you know
ho yeah I know a couple hos they do look
like pretty normal but they're they do
some [ __ ] going on inside the fabric
well for sure mmm what else you got
there's a bunch of these not that great
though well let's see Logan Paul
knocking out someone missing he's
getting ready for a slap competition so
um get ready online on it's on yon
instagram and twitter so he's doing this
cuz he's gonna go to rush and was going
to that was the plan right yeah he's
like doing basically a training camp of
slapping [ __ ] yes to get ready to
compete in the Russian constitutions
which Christ and then we'll just play
this real quick hey who's this guy stop
and we don't there's no dude I guess
he's practicing on
all right Hayden it's on you okay
bow angle banana Oh
touch him the guy's head didn't even
move great I've seen people get knocked
out from those slots before yeah yeah um
Logan what's this a now this is him not
doing that the competition anymore
due to unforeseen present a place to
impress I have to say that's pretty
smart
yes um he post that video with Chris
D'Elia and then Logan on Chris thing
said nah Brian let's spar and I thought
it was great funny and then the amount
of hate he got for even saying that and
then I was like joking around going
Logan you're way too big and too young
which by the way is 100% I wouldn't spar
that dude nah he's [ __ ] giant and
athletic okay it's too hard he's also
joke exactly a joking no one's been any
heroes no I'm just kidding Big O no
one's me take it easy he's not he's just
joking around lives in that's just what
that is there was a crazy they came at
him I was like that guy's [ __ ] around
he can't say one thing and they were
literally to do but somebody said look
at all the things I never look at this I
went over I was like all Jesus but he
seems like a nice guy but I would
realize it would definitely not spar
with him
you are so 50 dude I'm 52 and he's a
giant kid and he might not keep you
strong and boxes a lot I don't need to
get hit yes you could dude
yes he's he's Hey he's twinsies I think
I think he's 22 with 50 of money he's 22
so he's figuring his [ __ ] out he gets it
but he also learned so like this right
he's like this situation he goes holy
[ __ ] people get knocked out of [ __ ] up
from this I'm not doing this in my mouth
there's situation where he had like
those mini pigs you know those aren't
natural and real mean to animals when
people get those miniature pigs he
didn't have any idea I connect him with
Whitney Cummings she's like this is why
they're bad you can't you don't want to
put this out there and help people to
get the Enochs a type a lot like the
small ones they're called mini pigs I
think
oh and so it's like a new [ __ ] don't
highlight this Jim we know what people
let me see it but so they started to do
that and then Whitney was like yo you
don't want to do this because it's
actually cruelty to animals and Logan
Paul's like oh [ __ ] had no idea he's
like how can I contribute and make this
not yeah like geez he's 24 yeah yeah and
and I think what he's a damn out guy
smart insane amount of fear him and his
everything's under a microscope when
you're that way and but also he got big
from being outrageous he's outrageous
dude when you're sitting around with
money in the bank you like to wake him
with some knockout fraud they both crush
it right yeah absolutely crushing whole
business like it's not him just with one
camera guy and they upload videos to
YouTube I'm out and it's so straight
production a team high level team high
level people don't worry loves do and
getting paid crazy he's an entertainer
the people around him are very I mean
they work with some of the biggest stars
also he's a you can see from his body
and his a discipline dude like he did
that's he takes care of himself
you know what else get Jim all right
this is a crazy story
someone got impaled by one of those
Caltrans whatever type of tripods right
cuz homeless dude stole it and then
threw it over and overpass and it
happened to hit a veteran right near the
rib area so punctured his lung and his
rib but he survived he's gonna make a
full recovery is that a real picture
that guy's looking through the window
the thing so we're looking at this
earlier I think this is a they're just
taking pictures after that looks after
the case yeah that's silly
they don't be smiling like that no Jesus
Christ but he survived
he's gonna make a for cover there's some
[ __ ] throwing rocks off the [ __ ]
interstate and my people died well yes
he's like time yet to throw a big like
Boulder so people died people are crazy
man very crazy this here Artie Lange so
this is interesting because his nose
no it's gotten flatter than before so he
was arrested because he violate his
probation oh no what happened to his
nose it's just deteriorating no they
thought started glass but he he looks
kind of healthy other than the nose oh I
compare
other pictures yes but his nose is the
cartilage is all gone it's completely
flat now I don't even recognize him he
looks
I had a friend grown-up named Anthony
Turner not on the right but on the left
he looks identical my friend Anthony
Turner don't recognize him if he made
all the wrong choices I do not recognize
him at all completely different right
what do you get picked up for violating
probation and now did he have surgery on
his nose or did just flat out like a
pancake well maybe our jury I think you
had to have the classroom yeah but he
hasn't had reconstructive yet Rivera was
on Howard Stern I mean the monster on
Howard Stern tell one of the funniest
have parties I've known already 25 years
maybe in some ways the funniest raw raw
talent wise as a comedian like them off
the cuff funniest person I have a flat
dude you cannot yeah compared to that
oh go but what did what what's that just
roll down where his glass in his that's
where that's why that's when he snorted
a broken glass vial of cocaine right why
something like that why so it broke and
then he thought he cleaned it up but
then the shards of glass in the cocaine
still when he snorted it up you know
like if you had a cocaine and a glossing
drop it said I remove the glass I did
not die well it'll destroy your whole
[ __ ] dude what a tragedy yeah yeah well
it's heartbreaking caught up in that
weird you can't kick it
his nose is great this is a newest sex
scandal with a teacher she's a 20 year
old police officer teacher and stuff
starting to piss me off and she's 20
yeah at her go
I'm 18 year old 13 or 14 year old for
being awesome hmm for being a cool
person housing dealer when I was 13 or
14
he's 14 13 or 14 she's 20 yeah six your
difference Brian how old's your wife 41
Brendan that's just not anybody can't
drive my father saw Tom up way worse bro
no listen Brendan you can't just say
that because this old are you use a
grown
are you I'm 52 held your wife 41 Brennan
please stop doing that
no listen you can't compare age
differences between sales it's like
calling the kettle black your and also
your this is a double standard like that
was oh girl no crows loud girl you'd be
outraged this is a fortune oh boy I
needed to be more gender if she's a
well-developed fourteen-year-old god
damn it Brennan next all right next one
you heard recently that psilocybin
mushrooms were supposed to be
decriminalized in Denver apparently it's
not decriminalized it's just lower on
priority for cops so it's still illegal
to do so I'll give you a free pass
they're so busy thank what you didn't
[ __ ] mushrooms but it is important to
know that you can't just walk around and
have mushrooms what if they're
portobello mushrooms Oh psilocybin
mushrooms magic mushrooms where I'm not
much I'm not sorry I totally missed that
where you're on you know there's there's
news like oh that Denver decriminalize
the possession or whatever use of
psilocybin mushrooms that's not
necessarily true they're still illegal
it's just if you have a small amount and
you're a cop and you have other like
other drugs I get to worry about it's up
to the cop to be like whether or not he
wants to arrest you for it but it is
illegal okay hmm
I saw it from Tim Ferriss disposers had
dinner with Tim talk to him a lot about
that stuff he didn't tell you that no we
didn't talk about the GAO said that
stops talking about psychedelics and how
many he's really I think he might write
a book about it eventually I don't know
a finder's bet I would assume he writes
a book about it yeah it's a it's a
really interesting doesn't really do
talk about it yeah he's innocent dude I
want to go down I want to go down that
rabbit hole a little bit you do ever
since damn you old for that ever sinned
am T know ever since DMT I'm into
psychedelics
mom not know I'm interested in where it
takes what are you where were you gonna
go I don't know it's the same ideas
meditation where am I gonna go I think
that there are things I'm interested in
exploring my subconscious
exploring with what goes on I think
there's something there actually because
there's so many SmartKey whenever
well there I will but there are so many
smart people I know that are
that's true and I know that doesn't
necessarily mean that that but I I'm
curious about something I I'm I just
want to see what the fuss is about maybe
that's what it is because I'm getting we
did D I'm getting very into meditation
yeah and I thought that was badass was a
worldly experience to open up your eyes
no no no are you looking for a bigger
meaning of life and all that not really
I I'm curious about my own subconscious
but I'm not I don't think they're I
don't think secrets will be revealed and
I like your question I like your
question and I like your skepticism
because I have it too do you know anyone
who's just oh go on please say it
because it's an interesting conversation
in other words I know what you're saying
like like is Tony Robbins doing
psychedelics well was Einstein was do
you think Steph Curry's into mushrooms I
mean see I like you guys Ron James or
Steve Steve Jobs dislike you does Neil
deGrasse Tyson or there are a lot of
people including great Yogi's and
meditation contemplative athletes that
aren't doing it yeah but I - I guess it
may be a different type of mindset
because there's like rogue and super
super successful but woody but
regardless correct but he's always been
that guy I think the question you're
asking is why are a deeper understanding
one gains from doing psychedelic my I'm
on the side right now right now of
saying probably not well people girl you
open your mind yeah I'm hoping I if that
if you want to do it I don't that's fine
I just don't you don't feel you I don't
know I don't feel it right you don't
feel that there's a there there again
did DMT and I was in like oh my god it's
so clear to me now I got your friend go
to Mexico doing a bunch of shrooms and
he's trying to fight you know he's like
you I want to give me direction on my
god if you looking for shrimp for
Direction brother I don't a problem I
don't know man but you know what let's
say he goes there and maybe that's for
him it works [ __ ] yeah dude do all the
shrooms you want yeah
I just thought like if my son came here
at 18 was like dad I don't know what to
do I'm so lost
then shoulda saved my money go to Mexico
do a bunch of shrooms I'm like well
that's probably not the smartest choice
seven but maybe for this dude he's older
it's gonna work I don't know
yeah B I'm skeptical I'm and I I think
being skeptical about psychedelics is
smart because I am - no no now go down
that rabbit hole cuz I want to I just
want to see what's up I want to see if
there's I did have a bit of a
life-changing experience on mushrooms
when I was 24 I was younger I'm 52 now
kind of have a good sense of who I am I
have a good sense of what's important
the only good thing with mushrooms to it
like can't OD on them so it's all you
can get hurt doing right you know you
end up like Artie Lange I am [ __ ]
well that's 70 psychedelics and and
opiates for example or yeah I think if
you're doing it controlled environment
people know what they're doing it could
be fun yeah I can't express enough ABS
zero interest you can OD and die but
they say that some people they're the
worry their brains are wired they don't
come back from something that's the
scary thing for me so yeah so it's like
with mushrooms I'll do some [ __ ]
shrooms hey you just said you didn't
said you're not going to I'll do some
shrooms and [ __ ] everybody in here not
you cat what you two what leave cat out
of this appreciate what we hold and you
and I look like giant vaginas and asses
and he was just like oh I remember I was
a kid there's a rumor going around this
guy did acid or PCP I think was astir I
thought his skin was an orange and
started PSP that story I think it's face
I think a lot of us effect but I dunno
scared me enough though where it worked
I think not doing I do know that there
was a guy who they [ __ ] with and I
have maybe I know the guy he was kind of
a dick he did a bunch of acid somehow he
ended up in the bathtub and they should
take a bath it'll it'll help you he got
in the bathtub
and he started to feel like he was a
piece of chicken in soup and then
everybody was around I mean because you
guys are trying to make soup out of me
no legit gun and then my the guy
the people were scumbags and started
cutting carrots and celery and then
seasoning it's a bathtub and he's like
can we so and he was freaking out likely
to do that to somebody
yeah so yeah so they turned him into
soup yeah because there must with uh you
don't look like you've ever done any
drugs yet no nothing I mean I used to
smoke weed but not very much mmm gin I
didn't know I'm the first time I tried
ecstasy I did three tabs in one night I
had no idea you're not supposed to do
that much and what happens it they were
like [ __ ] everybody
they're like it wears off after like two
or three hours we're at a rave so I was
like it already wore off good though
felt amazing but the next week or so I
wasn't myself up and I was freaking out
suicidal ya know what not suicide about
like oh yeah your serotonin serotonin
levels drop you just use like Snickers
yeah you're definitely sadder down I got
sick I got really I got a really bad
cold right after I was just I guess I
get depressed I was like oh yeah you did
one I probably never killing Wow just
kidding present Oprah's in crisis
why'd you make them Brazil I don't know
there's no Brazilians in [ __ ] you Vegas
Weimer is very approximate you that
never happened is funny way can you
imagine exhale oh yeah sigh I'm trying
to my Brazilian accent you have to tried
it try did ecstasy it's good gonna get
you high
although Jamaican no jamia ma if you
would if you were no accessing much I
this ecstasy
where did you get it like down by the
Beach Boys tear off your face boy you'd
have a good time suck your drop boys all
right
well they're pros dude that's what do
you want to do take it easy dude we're
going to Vegas June 15 yes we I'm gonna
sold out 200 showroom ladies and
gentlemen I'm suck us dry yeah well no
because we're me make you laugh and you
know texted me was Matt Mitrione cuz
he's gonna be
I'm going to Indy bunny Indianapolis
June what Cecil is up there right yeah
he said you know this is I got no he was
who's the only person you know in India
I don't [ __ ] know idea I you know I
hate I hate the guess I hate this is
Scott I go I don't [ __ ] know a Scott
night Matt Matt you got a girl cuz it's
Matt Matt that just hit me with it you
know it because I had a new phone anyone
who's a personal friend of mine when he
texts me I did a lot of my contacts and
transfer over so when people text so I
do this is crazy and I go listen I lost
my phone I did contact yeah just tell me
who this is then people go really lets
[ __ ] up them Steve just give me your
convocation game hide yeah I want to
know it does me nuts
yeah well my phone my phone number is
out there right on places like Italy so
I get calls from people it's so funny
and now they're Brian Cleveland it goes
magical is knew a long time I just wanna
say what's up oh hell I'm like all right
he goes he's like he you know Mike
alright my friend goes man what are you
coming out here I'll get these guys they
chain you know feels funny but just like
well they just want to talk
they get like holy [ __ ] I can't believe
I got you on the phone that's weird
what is that it chin just one more have
you been to the punchline star Cisco
yeah yeah so there I guess to say their
lease ran out so they're planning on
closing it and returning to something
else so Dave Chappelle and some other
comedians are rallying to keep it open
it's crazy because yeah their lease ran
out most comics comics before prefer
that over cops really really now Cobb's
there's always the one you want to do
but I've done the punchline a bunch and
I love that Club but it's very small and
Chapelle comes into town he does the
punchline that that's amazing to me cuz
he's there now somebody wanted tickets
for Tareq and said can you get me their
initials but I was like there's no I I
called Molly over at the punchline who's
awesome and she was like I mean look
that she is so so I mean you know you're
not gonna I was I didn't want to push
ABS doing my favorite venues in the
world the only time I ever done cop I've
only been the punchline went out when
you were doing I want with you that's
right
Cobb's was I had great shows in the
punchline but copses I love tubs yeah
great great both great clubs same owners
you know is the same owners I didn't
know that
yeah oh I didn't know that cuz I'm doing
press they asked about punchline yeah
says I did punchline in Sacramento
mm-hmm Sacramento when I fail cities I
used to hate it yeah great
was there burn the fires good food yeah
clean downtown yeah
San Jose dope there's so many places I
could live I never thought I could write
San Jose sick Sacramento certain leaders
are sick I'll see San Fran yeah I
couldn't live and I don't know if I
could live there but I like I like
performing they're always good crowds
yeah
shut up to a [ __ ] punch line
hopefully they figure it out oh yeah
that it chin that's it's well kids chin
you know everybody's like are dealing
right know hey that's messed up like
she's got way more this shins got way
more nose than art or the old know that
one now that's not true look at chins
not from this layout from the site wait
let me see it's similar the exact same
nose but here's the thing dude it's a
little different game an Asian the woods
bob has a crazy nose that hopefully
figures things hey atlas looks like
Jeremiah Watkins compared to correct
yeah Jeremiah's looking good cut his
hair dude he looks good dude I've cut my
hair tomorrow bro I'm glad you mention
it I want to keep your own posting I'm
gonna do cut my hair tomorrow you know
you know I'm sick of great when I get
sweaty and I had great news right when I
get sweaty my hair kind of spreads I
look like mrs. Doubtfire I get the
Butthead yeah cut it dude
not go wrong anymore really why not
shave my head but I'm definitely
trimming it on the sides uh-huh
we'll see we'll see dude I'll keep you
know what come here can you Instagram it
like when I'll do that
yeah I'll do that we're gonna take fish
to these snakes take pictures yours the
snakes
what these are too boots those are
pretty cool how do you get all these
snakes what do you do like you just love
the new I've never seen those where do
you buy those not from never seeing
these don't be you're not gonna see do
me a favor bro never don't be [ __ ]
like you're in on the shoe thank you I
hate the UN in Julia Duane you [ __ ]
sweat come
bro don't act like you have this in it's
annoying
he got off stage last night like a
veteran he was just like yeah and I was
like hey man you don't [ __ ] stroll
off stage like that see you know act
like you've been doing this for 25 years
you come off stage ringing phone don't
act all like yeah I go I was a light
that was good okay you don't [ __ ] do
that to me
hey you know just another night bro yeah
yeah I speaking with other nights it
speaking of another [ __ ] city
I mean Cleveland next week Thursday
Friday Saturday Cleveland hilarities
those bad boys are almost show sold out
and then Burbank are you in town on the
8th um shopping friend no I'm not no I'm
in well Brian won't be there in
Indianapolis
well Brian won't be there but I'm gonna
have some funny people with me in
Burbank California
that is June 8th and a little Las Vegas
Brian iron Las Vegas together 200
tickets left one show one night only
Calgary and brass tickets just went on
sale tea fat K calm we got new shirts as
well on the tea fat K website giving
launched any day now so stay tuned for
those and then my special it's on demand
now so you don't need to wait for
certain time all you got to go to watch
it for free go to Showtime calm promo
code shop and you watch my entire one
hour special on Showtime for free go
there right now Showtime calm promo code
shop to watch my special full free
account Indianapolis June 6 7 8
I'm a helium comedy club get your tix
Vegas has you heard the 15th Tempe
improv June 22 the 22nd I'm excited
about that
Tempe improv June 20 21 22 get your
tickets complicated Apes start streaming
for free on Amazon Prime so get that in
the meantime you can get it anywhere you
rent or buy all right there it is
Brendan thanks kids you know what man
I'm excited for everybody involved this
do shrooms and [ __ ] man fun show just
the five kids
Oh